we're not worried about 15-minute time
limits anymore 45 minute long videos for
you guys copyright strike over with
we're gonna actually react in slow
motion
[Music]
now people are gonna think we do fake
reactions I know
we're gonna do a reaction today to
honest trailer die-hard
oh boy I love me some diehard I think
diehard the first one is one of the
greatest action movies of all time let's
not forget to talk to the camera it's a
pretty good it's pretty great action it
is a pretty great affection move well
it's so classic in so many movies have
copied it maybe not the exact like this
cop is in a building and but like dude
trapped in someplace where he's got a
fight on his own against you know a
group of terrorists yeah yeah yeah and
it's like you know define action genre
lot it was very violent especially for
its time like I watch it today I'm like
when Han shoots that one guy in the head
and then then Bruce Willis is like
startled madhan's
han Ohana's Enter the Dragon
Hans is Hans Gruber Hans Gruber shoots
at one dude in the head to this day I'm
like oh that looks pretty brutal when it
happens and this was like decades ago
I love honest trailers I think honest
trailers I watch very few channels
really consistent and honest trailers is
I don't like do a reaction review to
every honest trailer yeah um but but it
was just Christmas I mean diehard yeah
people's favorite Christmas I feel like
honest trailers is one of the very few
channels that I watch like every one of
their videos you know I like the screen
junkies fights I like everything they do
enough introduction talk people it's cuz
the copyright strike is over we're just
scared that is so much fun not having to
worry about time
this holiday season revisit the greatest
Christmas movie ever made
Oh some ways he'll kick off your shoes
and join the party
for a movie filled with amazing action
great heroes fantastic villains
hilarious comedy suspense romance
excellent stunt work a rich supporting
cast and awesome one-liners what you
thought we were gonna crap on die hard
the guys tank top is in the Smithsonian
for crying out loud
hahaha in a decade where every action
hero looks like an unstoppable roid
monster no one kicks more ass than the
guy from abiding who looks like your dad
John he's a New York cop out of his
element in Los Angeles
led by Franz Gruber one of the greatest
movie villains of all time which is even
cooler but it's his very first movie
well seriously way to hit the ground
running Rickman
but McClain is not alone me Reginald
veljohnson yeah after he was the cop and
Ghostbusters but before he was the cop
in family matters he was the cop in
dialogue I had the best diet or the best
judgment I shot a kid but a hawk gonna
come to moral support
just watch your ass and you make it out
of here to hit me I lace up for a movie
full of non-stop foot stuff make fists
with your toes fists on your toes that
is either a foot fetishes wet dream or
their worst nightmare or a different
even weirder Tarantino level foot
fetishes dream we are not here to judge
so experience the original masterpiece
that inspired countless knockoffs like
die hard on a bus die hard in a
Tunnel die hard on a mountain die hard
in the White House
die hard in the White House - die hard
in a mall die hard on a boat die hard on
this other boat die hard in a range die
hard on a train die hard in a play in
another plane die hard in the
president's play die hard in a play with
snakes and die hard but awful time
contractor starring Bruce Willis when he
still cared
haha grouper wax dolph lundgren
Call of Duty Carl the drug haze
authority figure this man has no dick
ties like your grandma and uber blah
that's the limo one ha ha ha die hard in
a building I was one of the best honest
trailers in my opinion well I mean this
is kind of reminding us all the things
that are awesome about die hard you know
it is one of the vent like it was the
most fun of like the positive one uh-huh
you know yeah cuz they found fun things
to make fun of some stuff here was
nitpicky with a lot of it was like jokes
you know as much as like the humor came
from like the stuff this movie did right
that other movies try a billion other
movies I knew of a few films I came to
mind that all see blew me away when I
was like wow yeah so many films that
don't do it one guy you know trapped in
a in a place you know trying to fight
Darris Moon oh dude that's ridiculous I
seriously had no idea about that like a
semi I had what I had no clue that it
was like such a what's the word for what
I'm like an outline no for a movie you
know yeah I mean that says that's this
part of the advice and save the cat is
just take a well-known movie and put it
in a different place yeah so died are
they're just doing that with all Oscar
films all like Best Picture winners
it's the revenant but on a train ah it's
the departed but that of your Catholic
Church
that would be strange yeah would be me
to confess a [ __ ] homo
no but this made me want to watch die
hard again this didn't make me my watch
die hard again I think die hard is was
such a brilliant film in a lot of ways
and one of my favorite comments was
Bruce Willis when he cared oh ye
well yeah cuz that virtually said that
he doesn't care he has said that like
that he's bored of doing action films
and stuff and love shows do some other
kind of films he has though like he's
done stuck he was on Broadway recently
for misery and really yeah James Caan
can was wrong Khan
James Khan's role that he was taking
over for and Broadway Plus oh and he's
done like other movies that are pretty
big dat or it's just acting primarily
like The Sixth Sense but that was a
while ago like I wish now he would do
something different because it's like he
keeps signing on to do these die hard
movie I just felt feel or he to cop out
like it just seems like his career was
because I saw this interview of Bruce
Willis on Inside the Actors Studio that
was in the 90s yeah and that's when he
starts saying like I want to start
transitioning out of doing action films
I'm kind of done with it this was in the
90s and he's like I'm kind of done with
the action genre I want to do some real
work cuz he comes from stage then he
tried doing other stuff it wasn't
panning out as well hasn't doing action
so he got like kind of nudged into doing
action again and now he's sick of it and
it seems like he hates his life and he
just does it for the money
he didn't sign on for Expendables 3
really arguably he still is the most
respected one out of like a lot of that
main cast chases to get them to well cuz
he's still a draw in a different kind of
way like he could still surprise you yes
because like the thing about die hard
that so cool is like it's not just a
cool action movie like he's really good
in it like yeah and we've seen him be
really good at other stuff he's really
good in the sixth sense and then
loopty-loop really Cooper's a lot of
action but his performance is fantastic
it's like a real character
yeah and that movie seems concerned more
with its actual story and and something
more than this being a cool action movie
cuz like you know the LA die hard
sequels are just kind of die hard Ripa
yeah pretty more at least the two recent
ones like there are things I liked about
two and
three you know my cliff freak this is
the fourth one yeah I live free and die
hard like it's alright that's when the
action started becoming ridiculous yeah
it's like there's only became cartoony
there's stuff I liked about theirs so I
found enjoyable about that movie I don't
know if I would ever watch it again
like I like Timothy Olyphant it's like
the second John McClane squares off with
a fighter jet you're like this isn't the
same no he becomes like he can do the
impossible yeah yeah yeah and he
survives anything yeah he just becomes
like he's not a regular guy anymore
yeah whereas in the first three he's
still kind of a guy who gets hurt what
was fun about live for your die hard
though he's gotta think at the time it
came out I heard what a vengeance hadn't
been out for many years and then it was
like that's when like old action stars
were like I'm gonna hop back into my
franchises you know so he hopped back
into um die hard and it was exciting for
fans just because it was like you know
Bruce Willis is back in action at that
time was a little bit more you know out
there yeah and still is it's a no I
don't just like like the only die hard
movie I strongly dislike is the fifth
one a good day yeah that was a good
[ __ ] horrible film like I saw all the
die-hard for like the first time I saw
die hard I saw all the die hards because
my engine marathon right yeah we did it
we did I went with a friend of mine to
the marathon at the AMC and it was like
20 hours of John McClane and it just
like it started off awesome and then it
was okay and then it got really sad at
the end cuz like live good day to die
hard is just such a depressing movie
that it doesn't seem like anybody cared
about I feel like we could do another
sequel and kind of ignore what happen
you know when they do that with sequels
what's kind of ignored this sequel that
happened yeah you know and I feel like
they could do that with a good day to
die hard he's gotta go ahead he has to
care like you have to bring Bruce Willis
back into capacity where he will care
and you probably have to do a story that
acknowledges the aging John McClane you
can't just have it be like dad want to
be a genero again like you have to yeah
you know like that's what I like about
what they would Stallone did with the
Rocky Balboa yeah
Creed yes he lets the character actually
age yeah exactly you you
have to acknowledge where Bruce Willis's
we attach that to jelly-like yeah
exactly like and what they did with Han
Solo and Harrison Ford and latest Star
Wars yeah and I feel like the die hard
franchise does need exactly what you're
talking about backed up with the
examples I gave to help give a
supporting point and to who you're and
together we have built a nice discussion
yes what we have done people I had no
idea that Alan Rickman's first movie
like clearly they show that he's done
like TV series Nessa but his first film
I feel like they wouldn't really give
opportunities like that to actors
nowadays for big [ __ ] films I don't
know I mean maybe like it's it's one of
those things that happens every once in
a while or maybe they just saw him there
like man this guy's got something let's
do it like naturally terrifying Alan
Rickman to me as someone who's
constantly consistently scary even in
love actually I'm just like I just
something about you just scares me I
wouldn't necessarily want to bring a
report to your desk yeah I wouldn't be
like terrified you to do something I
just I just think you'd think I'm an
idiot yeah exactly I don't want to end
this video without talking about
Reginald veljohnson yeah yes
Family Matters was a show I really grew
up on really oh yeah no idea oh yeah
don't you remember we were in Catholic
school there's a Catholic school that we
grew up in because we movie him altar
servers eventually yeah we did is it so
we can go to Matt's that way we could go
to Magic Mountain that's what they did
for altar servers they said hey you
become an altar server you get free trip
to Magic Mountain serve the Lord and we
will take you to experience this is your
reward but then a priest came and took
over and he was like we're gonna cut
that out luckily we had already
graduated from that Catholic Zoo I don't
necessarily blame them it gets kid makes
no serving for the running man but at
school one day they brought in the woman
who taught Steve Urkel like dance moves
for something they had so you don't
remember that
it was a choreographer and i'm agai
Saiga's about steve urkel might actually
be there but he wasn't was this like a
Wednesday really expecting Julia why is
this like a Wednesday assembly or
something that was yeah go to the
auditorium okay that stands out to me
that memory because I love Family
Matters and to see him play the same
exact character in die hard you'd like
to think that maybe that's just what
that cop did when he was actually out
yeah you know what my [ __ ] brother
once did what my brother at our Catholic
school every year the school slash
church has a festival and an actor
showed up this African American actor
and I went up to him my brother's I
didn't know who was the town I was like
six years old realizing who was many
years later upsets the hell out of me oh
I think I remember this story but my
brother says hey go to that guy and go
are you the guy from family matters
he had a crowd of people around him are
you the cop from family matters that's
what we have he said no and there's a
crowd of people around him right and I
go up to this guy and I say are you the
cop from family matters and he just goes
no huh it was Denzel Washington right oh
[ __ ] no [ __ ] Denzel that's terrible I
didn't know Denzel I only movie had seen
of him was virtuosity at the time for
diversity I don't know my parents were
really into that film for some reason
Russell Crowe is the back your brother
knew yeah yeah my brother was
intentionally [ __ ] with know cuz he
knew would have set me like a few years
down the road yes have you ever meet
Denzel you're gonna bring that you gotta
say something about Denzel Denzel about
how awesome he is hey dude I'm six but I
love training day however for Denzel to
be compared to the Kapoor family man
yeah
is this honor for him hey imagine old
you're the man people like Reginald
veljohnson even aged well he looks
exactly the same just a little gray
anyway guys look the video is finally
done copyright strike is over if you're
new to the channel click this button in
front of me to subscribe to the real
rejects
become a reject
today reasons to Giri Dhinka stubs on
this channel I'm societies like his
movie reviews and such and videos that I
started and adding to the playlist
videos that you guessed on it oh wow
thanks me yeah I would go through the
whole list that's a lot of [ __ ]
videos that I'd have to look out for
then add to the playlist it would take a
lot of time I'm glad you know it would
take a lot of time I'm glad to be out a
lot of videos maybe by like 2018 people
in Hawaii reasons to join in case you
guys don't remember Jerry is actually
the co-creator of the real rejects I
have been here 1 all the camerawork the
lights I do the editing everything on
this channel learn how to do from him he
taught me how to edit
I mean you've come you either tell me
many times hitting it buzz after the
word gum I I was like I made it how are
you this whole this whole time yeah well
then maybe I should show you my Bell
Johnson oh it's good though that's good
yeah links to the rest of the video bad
dank ass stuffs podcast he co-hosts with
this dude named Aaron and yeah check it
out immediately because Jerry's my best
friend and if you don't support my best
friend let's just say I will force you
to blow me oh just like one of my
favorite girls do that who is also black
know over that one movie oh come on that
black actor who forced that one guy to
blown oh yeah you don't talk about yes
they do and you more recent than fact
let's just say the last word of the
title
kind of rhymes with the word masturbate
except masturbates three syllables this
word is one syllable no it's the movie
babe
no dude enemy of the state
oh yeah good Will Smith forces Gene
Hackman